which of the players here confuses you
the most probably myself confused a lot
cuz I don't know what happens how did
this all happen
none of them confuse me I mean I've
played them so many times by now idea
they don't really confuse me I I think
that you start to get used to a player
style right now I'm finding it very very
difficult to play to play ding he's
gotten the better of me recently and
yeah he's a very very strong player
up-and-coming he's won won one of the
guys with with Khurana that I considered
to be to be the top contenders here the
camera the player that I sometimes
didn't understand him since I have very
best go against him sometimes I can
understand him probably if there is one
player that I would say that about it
would have to be ding now whether that's
because he doesn't I mean he doesn't
really speak that much English or
whether it's just because he's quiet I'm
not sure but when when I see his results
he's these great results but then when I
play him somehow I don't really feel the
same level of strength that I see when
he plays mostly the other guys so it
just seems kind of weird and sometimes
like a nabhi John it seemed like he just
wasn't really there at all so yeah I
definitely did not easy to say that I
can say if one name is it should be
Nakamura
I mean Levin can get into your head but
in a good in a good sense otherwise of
course I mean I've been saying all of
the players for so long now so I mean I
don't feel like they're confusing me
well I think that he he he
young Yamanashi is who can confuse you
either on a chess board and in life also
so he's very unpredictable I would say
like this I don't understand myself
sometimes for other players
I guess loved one to me is a very
confusing clear but it's not clear to me
which the one I'm playing that like you
could a good finish first place
interment very good of finish last
very unpredictable